do you have advice for young minds today
dreaming about creating as you have
dreamt creating intelligent systems what
is the best way to arrive at new
breakthrough ideas and carry them
through the fire of criticism and and
past conventional ideas ask your
question freely your questions are never
done and solving your own way and don't
take no for an answer if they are really
dumb you will find out quickly by trying
an arrow to see that they're not leading
anyplace but follow them and try to
understand things your way
that is my advice I don't know if this
is going to help anyone now that's
brilliant
there is a lot of inertia in science in
academia it is slowing down science yeah
those two words your way that's a
powerful thing and it's against inertia
potentially against us against your
professor in order to democratize common
sense in order to instill rebellious
spirits in students so they wouldn't
wait for until the professor get things
right she wrote a manifesto of the
rebellion against the professor and yes
you